Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and tonight on
Agents of SHIELD it was ladies night.
Roller Derby on a plane.
Jamie Alexander guest starred as Lady Sif
and Elena Satine debuted as Lorelai from the
comics.
Naturally there was a ton of comic book and
movie references and the mysterious blue alien
plot thickened big time.
So I’ll explain who Lorelai is real quick,
then we can talk about our top 5 moments and
then I’ll do a review.
Quick shoutout to my Avengers 2 video that’s
coming later tonight.
For my Marvel Tuesday bonus video I’m breaking
down the Age of Ultron teaser footage that’s
coming next week.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Now let’s discuss the weakness of all men.
Lorelia.
She’s played by Elena Satine who you may
remember from Smallville.
She played Mera, wife of Aquaman in an episode.
Funny to see her jump to the other team.
But this was a way better role.
In the comics Loki used Lorelai to distract
Thor while he was busy trying to build his
power.
The cool thing is that the story also involved
Malekith the Dark Elf we saw in the Dark World
movie and the Fire God Surtur.
In the continuity of this episode she had
been imprisoned for the last 600 years after
being captured by Sif, presumably after those
comic book events I just mentioned.
She escaped during the events of Thor The
Dark World, when Kurse destroyed the Asgardian
Prison that Loki was also in.
So now let’s talk about our top 5 moments
from the episode.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
it yet.
Number 5 - What Kind of Powers Are We Talking
About?
So you have to remember that for most of the
SHIELD Agents, Magic or sorcery or even mutant
based powers don’t exist.
Or at least they don’t know about them.
So the reveal of Lorelai’s powers does a
couple really cool things.
One, it’s just funny to see all the WTF
is Magic faces, but it also opens the door
for more strange powers on the show.
Which I think is laying groundwork for the
Clairvoyant.
That is, just making whatever strange powers
he or she has seem more plausible when the
secret is revealed.
I’ll talk more about the new Age of Miracles
that’s coming in my Avengers 2 video.
Number 4 - Sif versus the Biker gang.
This is really the first of many amazing fight
scenes.
It becomes pretty obvious that the ladies
are going to be having all the fun this week
and I think it’s awesome.
The biker gang fight was as much exciting
as it was funny.
Just watching Sif throw them around like rag
dolls.
And the joke with her pushing the giant RV
with her foot.
That kind of humor is straight from a Thor
movie.
Just the comedy that comes from putting a
super strong asgardian in a fight with regular
humans.
I was really bummed that Sif didn’t get
more action scenes in Thor The Dark World,
and I feel like this episode rectified that
mistake a lot.
She’s such an interesting character and
Jamie Alexander does an amazing job playing
her.
I loved that moment when Coulson knew she
was hanging on the outside of the plane just
because she was so tough.
Number 3 - Coulson questions Sif about Blue
Aliens.
There were a lot of comic book references
here, but Sif lets him know that only a one
species actually visited earth, frost giants
a thousand years ago.
That means one of three things.
Either a frost giant was captured or Nick
Fury acquired one from outer space or Fury
captured one that originated on earth.
I don’t know that he would have gone into
space yet, even though Guardians of The Galaxy
is right around the corner.
So the alternate theory to frost giant or
Kree is An Atlantean.
They have blue glowy skin and originated on
earth.
Meaning the theory fits within the logic Sif
presented.
That dispels my Kree theory, but opens the
door to Skye being part Atlantean.
If you’re not familiar Namor is half Atlantean.
So he has powers and can live underwater but
appears human.
Basically Marvel’s version of Aquaman.
This is big, so let me know if you agree with
the Skye Atlantean theory in the comments.
Number 2 - Sif Versus Lorelai.
This wasn’t as big a battle as I expected,
but I award bonus points for the creative
use of Sif’s sword during their duel.
There were also some awesome comic book references
to Lorelai’s old plot with Loki and how
she used Thor.
It’s so much fun to see them bring a comic
book story from the 80s into the modern day
Marvel Universe.
Remember Asgardians live for about 5000 years,
so 600 to them is like a decade for us.
It would be like us talking about the war
in Iraq.
Something pretty recent.
And my number 1 moment - The double double
cross including Coulson and Skye on one side
and May on the other.
So many things are connecting Agents of SHIELD
to the plot of Winter Soldier.
First let’s talk about the Coulson side
of this equation.
The person he was talking about tracking down,
that person who was “responsible” is Nick
Fury.
He’s off the grid, but we see him during
Winter Soldier.
So we probably won’t learn what he’s been
doing until the last couple of episodes or
maybe not until the movie in a couple weeks.
Then let’s flip to the other side with May.
She’s keeping tabs on Coulson for someone.
I’m betting it’s Robert Redford’s character.
He’d be one of the few people with security
clearance and power inside SHIELD to know
all about the blue alien.
But now it’s your turn.
Let me know what your favorite moment was.
All the roller derby on a plane fight scenes
or all the comic book references or the blue
alien plot.
Overall I give the episode an A just for amazing
use of a movie character Jamie Alexander and
a comic book character Lorelei.
I hope we get to see her in another Marvel
movie or back on the show next season.
Jamie Alexander got way more screentime than
she did in any of the Thor movies and I hope
they expand her role for Thor 3, her character
deserves way more screen time than Natalie
Portman.
And if rumors are to be believed, that won’t
be an issue.
I’m saying Portman might not return for
a third movie.
I don’t know what her contract says though.
Elena Satine was also so much more fun that
all of the other guest stars this season.
It’s like the Tom Hiddleston Loki bonus.
The actors playing villains get to have way
more fun and be way more complex than any
of the heroes.
Not to say that Sif isn’t a ton of fun too.
The only thing I thought could have been done
better was the Men VS Women plot.
I understand that it’s a slam dunk to do
gender humor like this when the villains powers
are all about manipulating men.
And the jokes were totally funny.
But I if you don’t need to make men seem
strong by showing women to be weak, then the
opposite has to be true.
For example, I don’t think you need a bunch
of weak men in a Wonder Woman movie just to
make her seem powerful.
Just like you don’t need to show a bunch
of weak women to make Superman seem powerful.
That being said, Fitz was so much fun to watch
being drunk in love with Lorelei.
And watching Simmons almost crack Coulson
with the fire extinguisher.
It’s too bad SHIELD can’t be this funny
all the time, but sometimes having super strength
and a bunch of Asgardians makes
it easier.
So
in related news, look for that Avengers 2
video later tonight.
You can click here to watch it.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
And you can click here to learn about my previous
Skye Ms Marvel theories.
Now expanded to included Namor.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tongiht!
High Fives!